for 39 years a las vegas woman named
vicki tatum has been waiting for her
husband to return home from work vince
tatum was a corrections officer sergeant
at the state prison near indian springs
and was investigating possible criminal
activity by fellow officers now metro
cold case detectives have the names of
the main suspects but they need help in
resolving this mystery the i-team's
george knapp has our story
he was a family man vicki tatum and her
husband vince had been married for only
two years when he vanished that was 39
years ago but she's never given up hope
of finding out who killed them i can't
even describe how terrible an awful that
is to be waiting for someone who never
comes home vince tatum was a decorated
corrections officer a sergeant at
southern desert correctional a state
prison near indian springs he had
undertaken a quiet investigation into
criminal activity at the prison the
possibility that fellow officers might
be involved in smuggling drugs and guns
to inmates and or a theft and
embezzlement ring he never told his wife
the details but hinted that something
was amiss shortly before he disappeared
he had brought home a gun it was a
prison issue gun and he told me how to
shoot it and he says if i'm not here
something happens this way you can
protect yourself at one am august 31st
1982 tatum finished his shift at the
prison drove toward las vegas and
dropped off a fellow officer donna smith
he said he was going to a confidential
meeting nearly a month later his body
was found in a shallow grave near what
is now a neighborhood at sunrise
mountain not far from the tatum home
he'd been shot five times in the head
with a 25 caliber weapon
weeks after that tatum's vehicle was
found at the railroad pass casino police
suspicions focused on fellow officers
including corrections lieutenant lovell
gaines at the time the president of the
local naacp and officer clyde johnson as
well as donna smith metro questioned all
three multiple times and they were
placed on extended leave gaines who had
been to the tatum home for dinner
clammed up and declined to turn over a
handgun he owned for testing a 25
caliber i know there are limits on what
you can say but those names obviously
appear in that file somewhere don't they
sure yes they were interviewed
every one of them cold case homicide
detective dan long was given this thick
file a year ago in response to a plea
from vicki tatum to finally solve the
case he says the original detectives did
a commendable job and it zeroed in on
the same three names gaines johnson and
smith but could never get enough to take
it further both gaines and johnson were
suspects and other serious allegations
at the time but those charges didn't
stick he does not believe donna smith
was knowingly involved in the murder the
good thing is that the suspects that we
suspect killed
him are dead
so the threat level is it's much lower
both level gains and clyde johnson died
years ago johnson reportedly made a
deathbed confession but police can't
prove it if you do know something
like i said we can solve this case
and
and
give the family some peace i feel like
i've been waiting almost 40 years
i feel like that prison at least owes me
an explanation
george knapp 8 news now